[Music]
every year relieves about 20-30 species
that are gone forever and using this
technology I think that we can preserve
and save those species that have been
lost scientists at the University of
Georgia are attempting to use DNA from
endangered cats to save them from
extinction what we're trying to do here
is collect skin cells from endangered
species and actually turn them into
sperm or eggs the goal is to develop a
tiger embryo and artificially inseminate
a house cat which will then give birth
to a baby tiger because of the extensive
knowledge of domestic cats reproductive
systems the risk of failure is
significantly lower than if using a
tiger as a surrogate we know that we're
going to have a lot of hurdles and so
what we wanted to start off with an
animal we know very well and so we
thought cats was a good starting point
the three-part process of creating an
artificial embryo begins with collecting
skin cell samples from endangered
species we got these samples from Zoo
Atlanta they collected the biopsies from
their Sumatran tiger and their clouded
leopard those skin cells are then turned
into stem cells which will later be
reprogrammed into sperm and eggs
allowing for the creation of an embryo
once we have these sperm and eggs we'll
combine them together we'll get a
developing embryo and then the idea is
we're going to transfer them into a
domestic cat and hopefully in a few
months we'll have a number of kittens
from that individual one of the greatest
challenges that the team has faced has
been developing the technique to
transform skin cells into stem cells a
necessary task that they have yet to
accomplish we are still waiting to make
that leap from skin cell to stem cell
and I think we're finally on the
doorstep were ready to go
[Music]
by collecting and freezing skin cell
samples from various animals scientists
are effectively providing a road to
bring back species that may become
extinct in the future in a single tank
you could have a bio bank of two three
hundred different species and enough
individuals in each box where you could
use this technology to repopulate lost
species I'll never give up essentially
you know laws I can keep doing great
science and exciting things I just
really think endangered species are
important to conserve and they're worth
the effort
[Music]
[Music]
this fuzzy little creature is a Kaka and
these guys live here off the west coast
of Australia on Rottnest Island
Crocker's are not only cute they are
camera-ready and they're taking the
internet by storm so let's start at the
beginning what is a Kaka Oquawka is a
small wallaby it comes from the same
family as a kangaroo and physically
they've got thick brown fur they've got
long tails and they hop around corkers
thrive on Rottnest Island because they
don't have any predators over here so
there's no foxes we have the largest
viable population of about 10,000 oh
sorry and you are
my name's Cassie Anna GREs and I'm a
conservation officer on right nest
Island in my role I'm responsible for
managing conservation programs and
there's one online trend that has really
helped these animals a cooker selfie but
make sure you're getting it right how to
take a Kaka selfie step one a camera
step two a corker but don't touch the
caucus ah nope
or feed them it's 150 dollar fine these
guys don't need the food they naturally
graze their way through the islands
vegetation and I also really love the
savings that we plan as part of our
revegetation projects that we have
implemented by our environment
technicians sorry about that guys thanks
for all your hard work and what makes
these guys so great for taking selfies
around the settlement area the Crockers
are a lot friendlier they've become used
to people so their natural behaviour
changed but out in the reserve where
they're actually still exhibiting their
natural behavior there will be a lot
more wary of people we have to know are
they actually smiling in photos yeah
they're not actually smiling in the
photo is it's just the natural shape of
their mouth which comes up at the side
which makes them look like they're
smiling
the popularity of the croc selfie has
given us the opportunity to be able to
raise awareness about the Coker's
particularly on the mainland that are
under threat so we use that as
a platform to educate the public and
also educate them about appropriate
interaction with wildlife
so finally a good cause for selfies
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
alimony in Kenya no wildlife
conservation areas they are quiet this
all changes when the phone rings topic
acai the team can be contacted at all
times
we are the first mobile security patrol
virtual team in this part of Kenya
typically an animal is trapped in
approach is near but it can be anything
a lion which needs to be translocated or
a sick zebra but usually does behind
our kids include Klaus first aid kit
medical supplies blindfold
Rob and Karen lab the team consists of a
driver uh Nesbitt and two ranges once
you have assembled everything we are
ready to go and save the animals
the roles are not usually failed most of
the time we play through the bush we are
going to see
enriched and more applicable than most
have another self has become debilitated
because of the snails multitude we only
have a few minutes ones and was been
tranquilized and it can be very dramatic
Oh bleep back in the compound we are
bigger team just have one more keeper
takes care of their funds our lab
technician takes care of the blood walk
a Kohana manages our online presence
this job is important because as is a
lot of conflict to human beings and
Wildlife
therefore in Division who save wildlife
from becoming extinct is very crucial I
loved so much to save lives and see
animals our and that is our calling
that's why I do
[Music]
these are sea turtle eggs and there are
two ways this situation can play out
there's either or there's so how can we
make sure this doesn't end up like this
well take a look again these aren't your
ordinary sea turtle eggs these eggs
could one day take down an entire
poaching network the story of these eggs
starts in Ann Arbor Michigan hi i'm kim
williams qian and i am a conservation
ecologist kim does research on a wide
variety of animals but we're here to
talk about endangered and threatened sea
turtles with sea turtles in central
america there's an issue of poaching of
the nests for consumption of the eggs
and so her team has developed a unique
solution to gather more information
about the poaching trade fake eggs with
GPS trackers we can hide these fake
turtle eggs in sea turtle nests our hope
is that these eggs will get poached
along with the others and transmit
information on their locations where is
it that they go after they're taken from
the beach but for this to work the fake
eggs have to be convincing they have to
have the right feel because sea turtle
eggs are kind of a little soft and
squishy they're not like chicken eggs
we've been using a 3d printer and a kind
of flexible plastic but they still don't
look quite right and this is when our
story moves to Los Angeles hello I'm
Lauren and Lauren works in Hollywood my
day to day job as they work on set as a
makeup artist which could be beauty
makeup prosthetics creature design wigs
blood so it made sense for Lauren to
help Kim make fake eggs we needed these
eggs to look realistic feel realistic
and so that's kind of where I've come in
it was like the best way that I could
use my skills making prosthetics but to
actually like help a whole species of
turtles this is like it's a dream job
after months of revisions it's time to
put these eggs to the test in Costa Rica
heigen you remember Kim she's here to
deploy the eggs herself on a protected
conservation area this is a place that's
very special because it's a very
important nesting site tonight a sea
turtle will come and I can test out
putting the false sea turtle eggs in the
nest not only will this project provide
Kim's team with valuable information on
poaching she and Lauren hope it will
inspire others as well wildlife poaching
can be abstract or too depressing to
even think about something about this
project kind of captures people's
attention here's this very simple unique
solution that I think then serves as a
jumping off point for people's
imaginations to learn more about this
trade all of us working on this project
are just doing it in our our weird
little nooks and wherever we can and it
just goes to show there's so many little
ways that everyone can help you don't
have to be making fake turtle eggs to
make a difference you can make a
difference in your own way
you
[Music]